you're just so wonderful everybody loves
you guys so much I mean did you have
like a problem there's a scene where he
uh kisses your feet and I have a broken
toe I now yes I do bless you I yeah
that's me that's my toe right there so
you had a a br had St toe I'm not sure
if it was stubbed or broken it lasted a
good 6 eight weeks but I think we
changed the foot that we played around
with I don't think Tim would have had a
problem with either no he wouldn't have
cared but I cared for Tim he just wanted
to kiss it bu you know yeah how did you
guys track like there the course of the
show is I I I'm I'm taking a wild guest
here 25 years it's in 30s isn't it 30
years yeah it's in 50s through the 80s
okay perfect it ends in
1987 and this feels so real to me it's
also this is an opport it's just such a
massive opportunity as an actor that is
so rare to be able to explore different
ways you can use your voice your
physicality I mean I felt like Mr Potato
Head how so well because Tim has loads
of different glasses and a mustache and
a different
wig that way I'm glad I asked I was like
I'm not getting that one I'm not picking
up
Jonathan and by the way speaking of when
you're older your 93-year-old
grandmother has seen this yeah she has
yeah and she also watched Bridgerton too
she did yeah what's that conversation
with Nana like well I tell you
with none because I know how I'm
watching and I'm like oh oh oh oh god oh
oh I mean I don't know what happened to
me I used to be so
cool she um yeah I mean she says you
know it's not quite like how they used
to make them when it comes to Bridgeton
but when it came to her watching
episodes one and two I had known she'd
watched it she said she was going to
watch it on Paramount plus and my sister
had come over it was my mom's birthday
and I just sent my sister in for lunch
and afterwards I asked her I said you
know how you know what did Anna say and
anything about the intimacy scenes and
she just said um I didn't know he had it
in
him I love it I like her yeah right
that's a great response all right we're
going to cut to a quick commercial break
but Matt and Jonathan are sticking
around and when we come back we're going
to talk to the rest of the cast of
fellow
[Music]
Travelers you